hey what's going on it's bill burton
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh march
21st
2022
[Music]
what's going on how are you
how's things in your world going is it
going good is it all right is everything
fine you know what i said i don't even
know i did i attempted to record the
podcast i actually didn't upload it i
was looking at all the teams that were
in march madness
and i was like yeah there's a lot of
teams you don't see in there i go and
one of them i said was baylor i was like
where the [ __ ] did
you know where'd baylor come from i
guess they won the championship last
year
oh
you don't come you don't come to me for
facts people
if you're new to the podcast this is
this is you know whatever all these
other podcasts are
you know where they're telling you you
know what you should be doing and what's
really going on man
yeah this is not that podcast
if you're new to the podcast if you you
know if you've listened for more than
you know half an episode you know that
that's what this is so yeah evident
congratulations to the baylor bears i
guess they won that
that doesn't even sound right
i didn't think they were good at
anything they had rg3 my whole life
that's all they ever had they had our g3
guy with the heisman trophy i think
baylor last time they went an uh
football championship like eisenhower
was in office
the late 1950s for those of you keeping
score at home
before richard nixon his pasty skin and
his sweaty upper lip
lost to uh j.f kennedy one on the radio
crushed it on the radio
lost
on television
which makes me wonder is john f kennedy
sort of the first
kardashian like if you wonder where
at what point did it tip
you know when you used to have like uh
that's not true there was always [ __ ]
right
if you go back
if you look at the uh
what do you call
like back in the day like celebrities
were um
like rich people
robber barons
and people be all fascinated about the
homes they lived in and they gossiped
about them and the asters the
vanderbilts
the rothschilds and all of that [ __ ]
then i think then then they get they
they wised up and then they're the whole
big thing now they just walk around you
know we our family doesn't have as much
money as uh as we used to
with all the descendants and all the
inheritance and all of that [ __ ]
keeping a lot much more low profile you
know we've given away a lot of money
that's what it becomes
i actually saw that you know
i think the hilton's married into the
rothschild family
okay
now i don't know what that means but you
definitely want to rent the penthouse in
that [ __ ] hotel chain
i wonder if they let you they probably
always say it's booked
some sort of sacrifice going on up there
um anyway i think i [ __ ] cooked my
head today
so amazing being a redhead my entire
life like i just know better
sun was only kinda out
was hanging out in a parking lot
you know i just made a mistake you know
what i mean
i made a mistake just every once in a
while i just i'm like there's no [ __ ]
way
that i got my 41
999
ninth [ __ ] sunburn did i really do
that did i really do that again
i thought the last time this is the last
time
but i don't know my head my head's a
little pink today
look like one of those [ __ ] easter
candies there the peeps except the pink
ones
it's not a good look you know
i mean general generally speaking i'm
already not a good look
i don't need to add the easter flare to
it but you know what i know there's a
lot of religious people out there
you know
who do not want you to say
that jesus didn't come back from the
dead after three days
you know
just don't say that you can make the
little kid thing you know the easter
eggs with the easter bunnies and [ __ ]
easter bunny
for um
for the kids you do that for the kids
right that's how you get them hooked
it's like baseball teams and football
teams having mascots that's how they get
the [ __ ]
the fan hooked the next thing you know
he's ignoring his wife and kids on the
holiday because he's trying to watch a
playoff game
he's telling him to keep it down as
they're in the other room trying to sing
happy birthday in a little
quieter [ __ ] key
what's a quieter key bill i thought that
was about dynamics actually there are
more quieter keys
everybody knows
that uh you know drop d is [ __ ]
louder
than standard tuning everybody knows
that [ __ ] and if you don't then you know
i don't know what to tell you
go put on a [ __ ] pantera record and
you figure it out right you figure it
out that's what i love doing
i love bailing on a point
with a big statement and then saying you
figure it out
you figured out because i can't help you
well you could just explain your point
bill in a way that makes sense you could
always do that instead of [ __ ]
acting like you have like a
some sort of speaking engagement
that you're late
for um
anyway guess what i'm finally right as
rain my digestive system is back after
whatever the [ __ ] happened to it
last week my god
i finally just plowed through it i was
like [ __ ] this i'm eating regular food i
can't eat another plain half an avocado
white rice
you know [ __ ] unseasoned oatmeal
jesus christ
that's been amazing like like discipline
to eat that bland
all the time and you're not addicted to
salt
or sugar
you're just walking around even keeled
i bet the average human being must seem
[ __ ] insane to you
just a crazy emoting fat [ __ ] mass of
like junkies except for food just
walking around
screaming and yelling at like a [ __ ]
red light you're just sitting there with
your [ __ ] half an avocado with
nothing on it sitting in your stomach
getting enough fiber
you know not late
not early just [ __ ] just sitting
there just being
toy to camry
um
anyway as you know during this uh film
shoot
because i'm wearing a lot of hats over
here and god knows my [ __ ] pink head
needs a break here i'm doing like
basically podcast sliders here so these
are only going to be a half hour long
until i get out from underneath this
thing um
you know
this [ __ ] movie has just been it's
just coming together man i'm getting
excited
i'm getting excited about it all right
let's do uh let's do some of these uh
we'll go right to the reeds man
let's go to the reeds i hope march
madness has been oh [ __ ] the [ __ ]
duke god damn [ __ ] michigan state
games on
wait a second
we just [ __ ] rapped did i get home in
time
oh billy ball game
oh this say hey kid with the pink
[ __ ] forehead
that's gonna look good on camera
tomorrow
jesus christ how many [ __ ] buttons do
you have to push to get the thing to
just just literally
just the [ __ ] channel two
cbs sports
did i miss it i probably missed that i
[ __ ] miss everything
i just found out baylor won the
championship
2022 women's basketball tournament
you know i'm really trying to watch that
[ __ ] but i swear to god they they they
run like 50 year old white guys
it's unbelievable when i'm taking that
from [ __ ] watching myself run today
on film
[Laughter]
um all right i must have missed it god
damn son of a [ __ ]
izzo vs coach k we're doing it one more
time
let me look up the score let me look up
the score spoiler alert
spoiler alert if you [ __ ]
let's see here
duke vs michigan state final score of
[Music]
the blue devils got him
coach k
gets izzo
in their last meeting there you go
there you go i know he hated losing to
carolina his last time at camden indoor
at least he gets izzo the last time wow
wins by nine
85-76 to advance
to the sweet 16 i believe the duke blue
devils
never really took the foot off the gas
up by four after the first half 39 35
and then outscored him in the second
half 46-41
congratulations to the duke blue devils
of durham north carolina which by the
way has one of the best soul food places
if not the best soul food place i ever
ate at best [ __ ] waffles i ever had
in my life
i forget the name of the place but
they had like this this butter that you
put on it that had like [ __ ] cinnamon
in it or something
i mean i'm not gonna almost passed out
before i had to do my show but it was
worth it it was worth every
bit of it oh my god it's march madness
so you know what that means sports
gambling ignore your loved ones bet mgm
everybody it's tournament time
it's march madness time one shining
moment um if you haven't signed up for
bet mgm yet use bonus code burp b-u-r-r
and you'll get two hundred dollars free
after placing your first ten dollar bet
if any team hits a three-pointer during
march match-ups here's how it works
download the bet mgm app and sign up
using bonus code burr b-u-r-r place your
first ten dollar moneyline bet
any uh on any march match-up game you'll
receive 200 in free bets immediately
after placing your bet if any team hits
a three pointer during march matchups
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you uh you use bonus code bur when you
sign up let me read that slower
you receive 200 bucks in free bets
immediately after placing your bet if
any team hits a three-pointer during
march matchups in other words it's going
to happen regardless of the outcome all
right
just make sure you use the bonus code
burp b-u-r-r
when you sign up headspace hey man how
are you today man really
go on have a think have a think
everybody seriously
how you doing me i'm exhausted how you
doing
i'm generally speaking i'm happy
just take a minute everybody
you know just shut life off for a second
um if you're feeling hyper or tired or
annoyed or just yeah
it's time to connect with your feelings
by starting what those are your feelings
is tired of feeling i think it is
is it an emotion
um it's time to connect with your
feelings by starting your mental health
journey with headspace man
we all say fine when we don't mean it
yeah because we don't dump our day on
somebody that's why you say that but you
shouldn't walk around sad though that's
why headspace is great fine isn't really
an emotion is it how many times have you
told yourself you're fine
when all you've really felt is anger or
sadness or nerves well i just say dude
it's fine let it go because you know you
don't want to [ __ ] do something
stupid headspace is specifically proven
to help you manage your feelings and
your mental health once you download the
headspace app and try their mindfulness
routine it takes just a few minutes a
day to change your relationship with
stress and anxiety start feeling better
from waking up happier to getting your
mind ready for bed in fact a recent
study proved in just two weeks headspace
can reduce your stress by 14
why don't i do this more
i'm getting stressed out reading this
whether you want to relive relive
relieve stress and anxiety sleep better
or improve your focus headspace is your
everyday dose of mindfulness for reals
man however however you're feeling
that's a great word however if you pause
however you're feeling
as opposed to however you're feeling try
headspace at headspace.com
burr and get one month for free
off their entire mindfulness mindfulness
library
that's head that's the best headspace
offered to uh so
come on bill maybe you need to meditate
so you can read better out loud this is
the best headspace offer available so go
to headspace.com
today
headspace.com slash bur headspace man
[Music]
all right what do we got here oh look
who it is mvmt
movement
all right in a tiny apartment in
southern california two college dropouts
teamed up to create a watch company that
broke all the rules with fair prices
unexpected colors
and clean original designs movement
pronounced movement mvmt grew into one
of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 countries across
the globe
globe
now mvmt has expanded into blue light
glasses that protect your eyes from
screens oh i could use those right now
minimalist jewelry
is that a watch i can't quite see it and
more style essentials that don't break
the bank all designed out of their
california headquarters man
okay they got unbeatable price point
movement watches have the look and
quality of a 400 to 500 watch but you
pay
you're paying at a department store but
cost a fraction of the price because
they were built online and owned their
process from start to finish
you get a beautiful watch
shipped right to your door for free and
if you don't love it you can ship it
right back for free they got blue light
glasses all right i got to spend all day
in front of my computer looking at these
goddamn screens and my everscroll blue
light filtering glasses are a game
changer
oh god i wish i had some right now i
know they sent it to me i love them and
i don't know where i put them it really
helps with eye strain and poor sleeping
patterns and i love the modern style of
the frames i have to get some more of
those
if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank then
join movement and get 15 off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to mvmt.com
again that's
mvmt.com for 15 off so the last podcast
me and my lovely wife were talking about
words
that we we've said wrong for a long time
until we corrected each other
like my wife i didn't realize because
she doesn't watch sports she said
athlete said athlete
and i she got me to stop saying uh
pillow
we need some new pillows for the bed
she's like it's pillow
not palo i'm like i didn't say paulo i
said pillow she goes well it's not that
either
and i'm like well aren't you just great
at saying what i do wrong all right
wrong so that inspired this person to
write it wrong word said for 30 years
hey billy saggy sack
i like that one i'm a 30 year old slow
brain from idaho
up until a year ago i was always i
always said acrost
instead of the the correct
the correct word across
like across the street he said across
a-c-r-o-s-s-e-d
there's so many words i do that you guys
get on me for say in any ways
instead of anyway
uh
another was
open instead of open
open
open omp omp
how would you say that
instead of open
open
i don't know
bill please have an
open mind and try to understand
i'm just trying to make it across the
river
thanks you old bag of soup
i don't even know what that means that's
[ __ ] hilarious why would you put soup
in a bag
yeah shut your mouth your old bag of
soup
that's one of those ones makes no sense
but it a hundred percent works and if
somebody said it to me like they just
did i'd [ __ ] laugh
all right driverless car convention oh
conversation
uh dear billy front wheel drive in the
snow
i work for an engineering firm that has
a big contract with a large tech company
we work on a small part of driverless
technology i won't get into the weeds
man of the tech or the problems but i
would like to comment on something that
hits close to home with you nerds
those evil nerds you talked about years
ago are out of control
you are way ahead of your time on this
one
uh billy bright idea these guys come to
conferences and investor meetings and
they espouse the most maniacal [ __ ] to
put it simply they speak about the world
as if it were their spare bedroom and
they want to redecorate
isn't that fascinating because nerds
have really been like glamorized that
they're like these harmless [ __ ]
people
um
you know
you know they're i think they can affect
more people than a meathead
where a meathead just sort of destroys
what's in front of them
and these guys nerds can reimagine a
whole [ __ ] society here uh this one
guy came in and started telling everyone
that choice was a privilege
and that tech is going to remove that
choice for the greater good
to hearken back to less i mean what in
the [ __ ]
i mean that is just that's one of the
most insane things i've ever heard and
as always that's why i'm telling you
stand-up comics
are are a distraction all of this [ __ ]
where they get offended by stand-up
comedy and comedy late night and films
and [ __ ] it's all just a [ __ ]
distraction
choice was a privilege and that tech is
going to remove that choice for the
greater good to hearken back to last
week's email on the topic you will have
no choice but to ride in a self-driving
car and take the route it wants you to
take
joyriding would be a thing of the past
it's not just private nerds it's the
government too they have their hands in
how all of this will get rolled out [ __ ]
these nerds driverless cars would be
amazing for people who can't operate a
vehicle due to disability or age which
is why i don't completely hate my job
but forcing it on everyone is [ __ ] up
[ __ ] bill
love you love the podcast
um
yeah and the bottom line is
is if the [ __ ] politicians can line
their pockets enough with it they'll
tell us it's a good thing
and uh i don't know
i don't think that that's something that
you can sell
uh
i like i feel like the right
that's gonna be hard for them all to get
on board with that
you know what i mean
you take the average like [ __ ]
redneck out there i mean that guy can
turn a lawnmower
in into a [ __ ] a usable car
i mean those those guys are amazing so i
mean and there's nothing they like doing
better than [ __ ] riding down the
goddamn road
you know all over their property nobody
telling them what the [ __ ] to do
i don't think they get on board with
that
i think the liberals get on board with
that one
we all and by the way i'm not trashing
liberals because we all get on board
with dumb ass [ __ ] at some point
they'll be each year
the amount of wildlife that gets killed
by
people driving cars they'll get on it
somehow like that
um all right badass thing i shouldn't
own
professional video well here's one for
you if everybody is microchipped
and somebody kidnaps your kid and puts
them in the car
then you know where the car is and then
they could tell the car to drive the
police station
that's how they'll sell it to you uh bad
that's why you should microchip your kid
and have somebody else drive your
[ __ ] car because nothing bad will
ever happen except we'll control every
decision that you ever make all right
badass thing i shouldn't own
oh i was talking about you know i own a
number of guitars which i think i'm
going to sell some of mine
you know what i mean
don't you if you can't play guitar don't
you only need one that you fail on
um badass thing i shouldn't own
but do professional video gamer
that's what he does or she does with a
sniper rifle
okay i kind of get that though like if
you're like playing those war games
you just wanted to have the real thing
you know i'm a dead drummer at one point
i had a green sparkle john bonham ludwig
kicked from the early 70s before i
realized that uh
it was one of the dumber things i could
have ever done like what else are you
gonna do bill you're gonna [ __ ]
you know you're gonna start dressing
like the guy
why don't you get your own drum kit do
you think he'd respect you if you just
[ __ ] bought exactly what he had he'd
be weirded out by a single white female
with your pink head all right sniper
rifle
hello billy bald balls
first time long time yada yada i'm
writing in about your prompt for badass
items that you own for which you have no
right to own i own a 1943 mawson
nagant n-a-g-a-n-t
russian sniper rifle
wow
it is a five-shot bolt-action rifle
developed in 1891. these guns are so
badass that they are still used to this
day
there have been photos of them being
used in the war in the ukraine
well i wonder how many bodies that one
has on it 1943
that probably went right to the front
probably shot some germans uh the reason
i own this spec spectacle of human
engineering is because of my odd job
which i think you get a kick out of
i'm a twitch streamer slash pro video
game player
pro video gamer sorry
i know what a video gamer is i don't
know what a twitch streamer is
besides the obvious you smoke some meth
and [ __ ] do a zoom call sorry uh i
play a zombie survival video game while
anywhere between 400 and 700 viewers
watch and chat along with me in this
game you can loot grow food hunt animals
team up with other players
rob other players etc i once even killed
another survivor by stealing all of his
blood
with blood bags until he fell
unconscious and eventually died
it's an interesting game
jesus christ you know but you know don't
[ __ ] do a joke about feminism um in
this game my favorite gun is the maasan
nagant
so when a viewer offered to sell me his
i jumped at the offer this makes sense
to me it's a fun gun to shoot at the
range but it's mostly a collector's item
hanging on my wall above my pc i'd be
nervous in some states to bring that to
a gun range
got ourselves a [ __ ] russian
uh
let's see the pic picture of the mawson
and pc all right i'm going to take a
look at this open the link
oh dude that's a beautiful badass gun
man
i 100 appreciate that
and you you're hanging above your screen
when you're [ __ ] doing that then you
got the real thing above you i think
that's sick
i think you 100 deserve to own that
thing
uh dare i say it's beautiful
good for you sir uh once
while shooting at the range at least you
go to the gun range with it i joke with
the friend about my poor shooting saying
well i do make a living shooting this
gun at video games which the range
supervisor overheard i don't think i've
ever seen someone so confused in my life
uh you might find yourself wondering how
the [ __ ] can this nerd make a living
playing video games while people watch
to which i respond
how the hell does billy thespian making
a liv make a living talking to himself
in a room while googling the news and
calling his listeners [ __ ]
well touche you thought i was good no i
i um
my god sump one of his favorite shows to
watch is
watching this kid on youtube playing
this video game just kicking ass doing
it i mean
it's weird as that sounds to my
generation though we used to go down
back in the day if there was somebody
like
just unbeatable at pac-man or asteroids
people would gather around the the video
machine and watch them i never did that
[ __ ] but i used to watch it on the news
and i used to hear stories like yeah he
gets so many free guys if you stand
there he lets you play while he goes to
lunch and then he comes back
the guy played for like nine straight
hours
once you beat it so many times half the
screen goes black like that [ __ ]
um
i think you deserve that gun man i think
that's cool as [ __ ]
uh badass thing i own but not made for
me
hey insert funny insult here i'm not
creative sorry but you're honest
you are honest that's great last podcast
you were talking about badass things you
own but that you secretly know weren't
made for you
um i have a dirt bike
that i know was definitely not made for
me dirt bike that's a badass thing to
have i'm 26 and live in norway when i
was 19 i decided i was going to trade in
my then almost brand new dirt bike for
this piece of junk 30 year old dirt bike
why well because for some reason i had
to get myself a two-stroke
so for those of you who don't know what
a two-stroke is that's basically uh
every time the the the piston comes up
in the cylinder the spark plug fires and
sends it down and then it comes back up
one up bang
down bank down bank as it forwards to a
four-banger where it
spark plug fires fires it goes down
comes up comes down goes back up fires
again
basically two strokes i don't know if
they
environmentalists didn't like was they
were they were burning like twice as
much fuel obviously i think or burning
more fuel and they were bad for the
environment but everybody know that
rides bikes
it says as loud as they are and [ __ ]
they're awesome because they have like
this [ __ ] jump to them um so anyway
so i ended up with a neglected and worn
down
kx 500 back in the day the k
the 500 cc two strokes were the top
class in motocross and just about
anything else dirt bike related
basically i spent way too much buying
this bike and i spent an even more
insane amount of money just restoring it
in a shed on my parents property
dude this all sounds like badass [ __ ]
you bought an old bike and now you're
fixing it up anyway when i show up at
the local track everyone looks at the
bike like holy [ __ ] it's a 500 then when
i actually ride it they're like holy
[ __ ] this guy sucks
oh
well you're the mechanic
all you have to say to them is did you
build your [ __ ] bike
i restored this thing okay maybe i'd
ride better too if somebody gave me one
that was already built
all right you blonde dirt bike driving
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you say in norway
uh but honestly i don't care the reason
i wanted a two-stroke was because i
think they're more fun and i'm having
fun and when i'm riding my 500
and uh why should i care what everyone
else thinks you shouldn't i remember
vaguely something about you asking for
advice on dirt bikes particularly two
strokes versus four strokes neither of
those matters at the end of the day they
both require regular maintenance and the
better care you take of your bike the
longer it lasts the only thing that
matters
when buying a dirt bike is ergonomics
get a bike that fits your size and then
replace the springs with springs that
fit your weight
look at this guy he's a gear head this
is great by the way i hope that you make
it back to norway soon i loved your show
in 2019 especially the one story you had
about the icelandic lady that asked you
to push her down a hill
i was in norway in 2019
i guess i did i did that i did a run up
there
yeah the icelandic lady asked me to roll
her down the hill i remember that
[ __ ] weirdo man
um
anyway we're getting up against it here
um
i actually was on the ducati website the
other night i want to buy a ducati buy
like a street bike
and just ride it around the little
[ __ ] airport where i
you know fly helicopters and [ __ ] and
i'll just be safe there you know
it's just too you know
it's too cool a thing to not do
i just don't want to get killed you know
so i basically don't have the balls to
do it but so if i did that that would
literally be a thing i should known
um
but at some point in my life i do want
to ride a harley road king
on the street and i also want to i want
to ride a ducati at some point
i just rode for so little in my life i'd
be afraid to get on a bike
of that stature and [ __ ] it up not even
myself i mean just do something stupid
and [ __ ] i don't know what
um but i definitely miss it um i got a
little four-wheeler i bomb around on
every once in a while all right
underrated slash overrated underrated
yogurt
granola and honey for breakfast i've
been on this kick since i came back from
vacation i no longer eat a blueberry
muffin and coffee every morning yeah
dude that's gonna kill you
when lunch comes around i'm less hungry
and i've lost 15 pounds in three months
i look great and can see my dick again
almost
that's great also i haven't had the
stomach problems i was having i think
you should have
should have some to help heal your
raging gut i'm tired of looking around
my office at all these fat bucks and
feeling good about myself because i'm
not fat just out of shape
uh i [ __ ] hate sloth like atmosphere
i mean
i hate the sloth-like atmosphere i'm in
every day
all right oh i thought you'd have an
overrated
yeah underrate you got to get the greek
yogurt without all the sugar and all of
that [ __ ] yeah it's great for your
probiotics
from what i heard i've never heard of a
probiotic until the other day so i'm not
going to lie to you all right and with
that that is the monday morning podcast
slider
edition
um
i hope you guys uh
have a wonderful couple of days go [ __ ]
yourselves and i will check in on you
on thursday we're getting down to it man
i only got two more weeks left
shooting the movie and then i'll be back
to uh
full scheduled podcast regularly
scheduled podcast all right
that's it i'll see you